we begin this morning with an apparent
hacking attack that's threatening to
disrupt the high-stakes presidential
election in France an election that
could affect all of Europe the campaign
of centrist Emmanuel macron claims it
suffered a massive and coordinated
eleventh-hour cyber attack with leaked
documents designed to destabilize
tomorrow's runoff election Makram holds
a large lead over far-right opponent
marine lepen
the attack is prompting Frances Election
Commission to hold an emergency meeting
today
Mark Phillips has more from Paris mark
good morning
good morning well there are a lot of
issues around this hack including of
course who did it and why the timing is
very curious it comes at a point here
where campaigning has officially stopped
and so has the reporting on it and the
French Electoral Commission says in fact
that any reporting on the details that
the documents in the hack could be
illegal it was the campaign of Emmanuel
macron who's well ahead in the opinion
polls going into this vote which
released news of what had called a major
hack into its communications late last
night it said the documents were regular
campaign communication including
financial information but also said fake
documents were inserted into the list by
the hackers links from WikiLeaks showed
lists of documents but whatever is in
them may have limited of any influence
on the election results because of the
official news blackout all campaigning
and coverage ceases in France a day
ahead of the vote in what is supposed to
be a period of reflection for the voters
but the macaron campaign is clearly
furious it called the hack an attempt to
destabilize democracy except and
compared it to the accusation of Russian
hacking
on the Clinton campaign during last
year's US election suspicions here two
faults on the Russians and a possible
attempt to benefit the faltering
campaign of marine lepen who was jeered
out of one of her own rallies yesterday
the pen the right-wing anti-immigration
candidate is known to be less hostile to
the Kremlin she even met with Vladimir
Putin during the campaign and has
received campaign funding from a Russian
bank maybe the election will produce a
surprise she says it would have to be a
massive surprise to overcome the 20% gap
by which she's trailing going into
tomorrow's vote still with neither of
the two remaining candidates coming from
the established political parties this
election has already produced a surprise
there are a lot of parallels between the
election here and the one in the US last
year to outsiders as candidates
allegations of fake news and now of
course this hacking and in the end Alex
of course there will be an upstart as
president of France Mark Phillips in
Paris thanks mark